what's up were one of your many
notifications at 7:00 p.m. Pacific
Standard Time 10:00 p.m. East Coast time
how you doing John I am doing swell
Gregory how are you good good we just
got back from Christopher Robin at a
press screening because we're important
yeah yeah we were part of the press it
takes some well thank you it on the
press yeah there's all fake news
we're paid to say this with popcorn I
want to talk about a couple of things
before talking about the actual opinion
of this movie there's all the signs that
were leading to a bad movie with the way
this press screening was handled were
people just throwing shade at you in the
movie like don't even don't even don't
even oh yeah hey the embargo says you
can't release your review until 7:00
p.m. which is usually the time when new
movies start playing on a Thursday night
so there should be a screening of this
movie right now yeah your local theater
and then the other sign is they provided
food at the screening and they rarely do
that and they usually do things like
that to butter you up - yeah they
usually do things like that to butter
you up because there's a bog orchid they
usually do things like that to make you
enjoy the movie yeah say I ate all my
food before they do anything I was kind
of like a little hesitant because those
are usually all the signs that you're
about to watch a movie that the studio's
don't have faith in and I was halfway
through this movie going why cuz I think
I'm in love with this movie and then by
the time it ended I just knew for sure I
love this movie I loved this movie and
you got to keep something very specific
in mind here I have zero winnie-the-pooh
nostalgia I only know of some of the
characters through fragments of
information I've picked up over the many
years I can't recall one cartoon I've
seen I I really have no built-in love
I'm like you like yeah I'm the polar
opposite side of the spectrum
he was like Winnie the Pooh is something
I've had in my life since I could form
memories you know like I had my yes bear
I had the books I had you know various
episodes of the show and the movies and
stuff and so what do you think I really
enjoyed this - it really touched my
heartstrings you know in ways that I was
hoping it would and I was afraid it
might not because this movie seemed a
bit like a tall order to me or at least
like it could go wrong in the eyes and
it just had that dear sweet genuine
quality to me about it and I really
appreciated that I was very positive and
their reactions we did for the trailers
it looked like just a very endearing
simple pure movie about love and
spending time with your family basically
anything the trailers set me up to
expect and to want for this movie to be
good on and what to deliver I got I got
it all like I got more I really enjoyed
the hell out of it first off like any
time to actually review this just saying
I love it the movies called Christopher
Rodman and Ewan McGregor does a
fantastic really yeah it's like you got
to keep in mind this is a family film so
there's so many elements are gonna be
corny there's some elements are gonna be
cheesy but there's a lot of leeway for
that with this kind of films yeah I mean
the point of this kind of movie is less
about like a groundbreaking plot and
more about the qualities within you know
the things that's gonna make you feel
and you know the way it handles its
little lessons and stuff like that and
yeah the the dear simplicity of it all
for Winnie the Pooh especially like I
said no built in nostalgia for Winnie
the Pooh I don't really know what makes
Winnie the Pooh's personality so
appealing for a mass audience I feel
like this movie aims to serve two
purposes one is a feast for fans of
Winnie the Pooh and another one is an
introduction for newcomers like myself
and as a newcomer I fell in love with
Winnie the Pooh I think he is so funny
in this film and the messages that all
keep coming across about how sometimes
doing nothing is plenty sometimes doing
nothing and slowing down will allow you
to have what you really are searching
for and be life open to what might come
your way yeah instead of just trying to
force everything to happen just as you
needed to yes I'm trying to be in
control and then also to not fixate so
much on things
that we define to be the most important
things in our life but what's really
important are the connections we have
and spreading the love and joy like
these message is really it home for me
and the filming but a lot of people
compare this to a movie like hook which
I have similar plot setups
especially when you have like you know
Peter Pan and he's all grown up and he's
got a lot of us childhood I'm living
with your imagination and stuff there's
similar elements here but I think
they're executed wildly different yes
through the scope of Winnie the Pooh and
through yeah tambour those kinds of yeah
emotional tones the journey that
Christopher Robin goes on meeting up
with all the other animals you see in
the trailer that owl and rabbit are
actually an owl and a rabbit and I think
the effects on them are great there's a
lot of the time where I'm watching
especially characters like piglet and
Pooh Bear the choice to stay true and go
with the stuffed animal look just like
the toys used to have because that does
give a perfect bridge I think between
the fantasy and the reality yeah of the
movie instead of going for like oh let's
do it like in the animated cartoons and
stuff you know well I think Marc Forster
his direction usually relies on handheld
camera work and I think that allows
things to look actually more realistic
and a lot of these shots something about
when you hand hell in front of a CGI
thing it naturally can make it feel more
real and it works here I think
especially with some of his more
observant choices because there's a lot
of stuff that's like shot from afar you
know like you're watching this moment
yours peering in on it like you would in
a storybook and very reminiscent of the
illustrations yeah I feel like my only
real like film criticism didn't have
about it it came very early on in the
movie you know it's a family film and
then early on when they're setting up
this story of Christopher Robin and who
he was the journey he's gone off turning
into an adult and forgetting about his
past in a hundred-acre wood and all that
just leaving the innocence of childhood
behind yeah all that it's like very real
yeah a lot of hugely human stuff that
Christopher Robin had to go on yeah and
then suddenly there's some wacky stuff
with his co-workers that occur I thought
my guys got feeling totally weird now
because you were just very realistic and
now it's kind of a wacky film but it's
not too long
for the film really finds a good tone to
balance things out where it can hop in
and out of its comedic elements and its
dramatic elements pretty well because
there are times where it gets pretty
dramatic it gets a little dark at times
yeah and I admired that too because that
gives everything a weight and that
provides a good contrast between the
more uplifting messages and and that's
not something I remember we need to do
shying away from you know is reality
yeah definitely cuz there are even books
we're in about like The Tao of Pooh's
were like the philosophical undertones
and I don't think it's interesting that
if you look at all the animals they are
all kind of one shade of a personality
in a way yes definitely there were a
couple of people after the like we have
no idea what the reviews are on this
film yeah we have zero clue as we're
filming this it is the night we saw it
and your guys are getting this the next
evening no idea what people are saying
about it but the general consensus for
most people I talked to at the screening
was they thought it was cute they
enjoyed it some people loved it some
people just thought it was okay and
there's no people who would like this
and they're criticizing it I'm going I
don't think you've got the point of this
movie it's not supposed to be some
really profound totally unique it's
going back to the basics yeah it's a
simple tale it's supposed to be a simple
tape it is more about its earnestness
and its dear earnest and again those
emotional tones the imagination and
those little lessons about heart and you
have family and things like that the
movies about slowing down and getting in
touch of the simplicity of life so to
deliver a film that is a simple family
film that is delightful heartfelt is
exactly what it should be I think and I
think if you want to I think there are
things you could read into it if you so
choose you know you could view the
Hundred Acre Wood and the different
animals again as sort of a mental
spiritual retreat of some kind if he
chose to not to suggest that this is the
deepest movie ever but for me I was
really delighted by the trailer but I
had worries because this wave of
Disney's live-action films based on
their it's hazardous in some ways and I
walked out really happy and really
satisfied but it's really happy I cried
a couple of times for sure the right
kind of tears you just want to feel is
it predictable 100 million percent
predictable no but the thing is though
what
you're predicting you want to happen you
want that to occur so when it does occur
it's satisfying that's that's I think
about context yeah yeah I thought most
all the choices they made were salad
everything was in earnest all the actors
are here that was great the little girl
plays Madeline is great I don't see
Carmichael like and that's another thing
too is it is a contained story for as
much as I was worried in the trailer
about the whole thing where they go to
London the main action of the movie is
mostly about Christopher Robin his
stuffed animals and then his family and
a couple things with work and and that's
it and that's all it needed to be oh
yeah guys I love this film I might
consider one my favorite movies of the
year honestly just because I love its
heart you guys can do me a favor as a
newbie it made me go I want to check out
some more winning the Pooh stuff now so
watch you guys leave comments below of
what your favorite woody the Pooh thing
is to recommend to me to go check out
because I'm open to recommendations
right now you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation please click that
notification Bell thank you to everyone
who's checked this out on patreon lately
it's been an awesome how much it's been
growing over there thank you guys so
much
full length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
is music video coverage would love to
have you become a patron inject today
[Music]